on the surface ready player one is
stuffed with pop-culture references but
a little deeper within the movie as some
crucial details and messages worth
exploring
yippee-ki-yay lovers it's Jan here and
today I'm explaining the ending to ready
player one and that final scene between
Wade and Holliday Plus what it means for
a potential sequel if you're new here
and enjoy this video remember to Like
and subscribe for more stuff like this
of course spoilers ahead for the movie
so take care if you've not seen it yet
ready player born assess in a dystopian
future in which people escape the real
world by visiting the Oasis a vast
virtual reality universe co-created by
designer James Halliday and his friend
Ogden Moro
but when Halliday dies he sets a quest
for Gunter's to track down one easter
egg that will unlock a fortune and give
them complete control of the Oasis it's
when Wade aka Paz eval begins to
research holidays archives that he
discovers the secret track behind him in
the race that leads him to the first key
wadies holidays fear of going forward to
figure out that he needed to go
backwards this is the first example of
wage taking time to connect with the
game's creator James Halliday which
helps him to figure out the answers he
needs this theme is taken forward and is
crucial to the whole movie plus it's
also how Wade got the extra life coin
which came in so useful later on wave
makes the next breakthrough and is part
of a lab ATAR teams up with artemis and
the rest of the high five and they work
together on the second challenge the
setup for this is a stunning recreation
of the shining and again to crack this
challenge the team have to understand
Halliday's personal history and failings
it was when Holliday gave up trying to
communicate with Kira who he loved that
he retreated from the world and broke of
his friendship with Ogden morrow at this
point in the movie it's Samantha aka
Artemis who has the emotional depth to
properly understand the situation and
she realizes that Kira needs to be freed
from the kind of emotional prison that
Halliday is trapped her in Artemis
realizes the leap that Halliday referred
to in his clue is more than a literal
leap so in the Overlook hotels ballroom
she jumps over to Kira fighting off the
zombies and asks her to dance the very
thing that Halliday couldn't bring
himself to do the final key and
challenge involves a game called
adventure although the villainous Nolan
Sorrento's team eventually figures out
how to win the game they find their
dismay that winning doesn't actually get
them the key instead as Wade discovers
what Halliday wanted players to learn
was that it's not about winning it's
about playing rather than triumphing at
the game Halliday wanted the players to
discover the game's Easter egg and in
that way connect with the original
creator by the way in real life Atari
which developed the adventure game in
the 1970s refused to give credit to
their games designers and programmers
and so this digital easter egg was how
one particular designer Hidde credit for
himself in the game the message that
Halliday and ultimately Spielberg seemed
to want to convey and ready player one
is the idea of a player forming a bond
with the inventor playing the game in
this way transcends the limitations of
simply trying to get the highest score
or winning and instead it means the
creator and the player can enjoy a shirt
moment in fact the connection between
characters audiences and the filmmaker
is a recurring theme in Spielberg's
movies films can feel like ongoing
conversations between a director and
their audience and can create a
long-lasting sense of closeness between
a filmmaker or film and us viewers
speaking recently at a ready player one
event at South by Southwest
Spielberg noted that when I decide to
make a movie sitting in the audience
with you I direct in the seat right next
to you and your reaction is everything
but not only to Spielberg prize that
strong connection with his own audience
he also feels that bond with the work of
other filmmakers too indeed he's talked
previously about the unforgettable
effect on him of Stanley Kubrick's 2001
a Space Odyssey and David Lean's
Lawrence of Arabia and it's interesting
to see this idea of a deep connection
emphasized again in ready player one in
fact it's that understanding that allows
Wade to realize that if he signs
holidays contract for sole ownership of
the Oasis he'll make the same mistake
that Halliday did when he lost his
friendship with Ogden Morrow his partner
in gregarious games and that's when
anorak reveals the secret prize beyond
the ownership of the Oasis
to meet Halladay Paz eval enters a room
with Halladay where a young Holliday is
sitting playing a video game in that
childhood room Holliday gives Wade the
real Easter Egg prize explaining to him
that he created the Oasis because he
never felt at home in the real world and
he didn't know how to connect with
people but Halladay adds that just
before he died he realized that although
the real world was scary to him reality
was in his words the only place you
could get a good meal and the only place
that's actually real like Halliday
Spielberg is often talked about how his
own fears of fueled his filmmaking over
the years providing the starting place
for many of his projects I think that
the stories always vanquish the fear and
in a further echo of holidays words in
the film Spielberg recently stated in an
interview with E W that Escape has its
pleasurable and medicinal place but
total escape should not be a destination
so in the end Wade shares control of the
Oasis with his friends the high five and
they decide to close the Oasis two days
a week to encourage people to
participate in the real world and
connect with other people there and
what's curious about that last scene
with Holliday is that it implies that
what we're seeing is an AI version of
the man it's almost as if Holliday
managed to duplicate his consciousness
and upload it into the Oasis to live on
and make sure an appropriate successor
was chosen to inherit the virtual world
it's an interesting theory and would
also allow for holidays character to
return should a sequel to the movie ever
be made so what did you think of ready
player one and would you like to see a
sequel and what were your favorite
moments or Easter eggs in the film aside
from the shining sequence one of my
favorites was there Zemeckis cube which
turns back time in our March to Back to
the Future director Robert Zemeckis let
me know what you enjoyed most about the
movie in the comments below and if you
liked this video I really appreciate a
thumbs up and subscribing you can also
check out more videos you'll like right
here
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers